a large part of china has been enduring
a record-breaking heat wave over the
past two months that is in addition to
record low rainfall and similar to what
is happening in europe and the western
u.s the lack of water has started a
domino effect of trouble for 400 million
people in china and could worsen the
already weak economic growth in the
country where nearly 20 percent of its
electricity comes from hydropower
raymien ascencio reports
summer is the rainy season for china's
southwest but dry cracking riverbeds
like this across the 4-thousand mile
yangtze river questioned that fact
china's biggest freshwater lake the
parched polyang has shrunk by 75
that change clear in these satellite
images taken in august of last year and
now
falling rivers have revealed forgotten
treasures these buddhist statues from
six centuries ago
and so-called pagoda island no longer an
island but a mound of earth where
seemingly lost fishermen step out onto a
desert landscape
they're calling it uh the worst in
recorded history david fishman is an
energy expert in shanghai
talk to me about how frequency of
droughts is changing in china we see
these events not happening once every 60
years anymore maybe once every 15 years
maybe once every 10 years
shocks are rippling from countryside to
coast
the heat is scorching my sweet potatoes
to death says this farmer and many
factories have been shutting down from a
lack of hydropower
volkswagen toyota and foxconn which
makes parts for apple have shortened or
ceased production
government officials are doing what they
can from seeding the clouds to force
rain down
to releasing water from the world's
biggest dam the three gorges
and to switching off the lights in
shanghai to save power
but it will not be enough china's heat
wave and drought are forecast to
continue through the end of this month
with their frequency only surging in the
future for cbs saturday morning raymie
in ascencio london